also quarantäne verkürzen oder sogar weg
mit der quarantäne für all die die nicht
krank sind sondern nur kontakt hatten zu
einem infizierten darüber wollen wir
streiten ihrem studio mit unserer bild
kollegin kolumnistin nina schenk die
sich seit tagen seit wochen aufregt über
diese quarantäne regeln die jetzt dazu
führen könnten das ist eigentlich das
ganze land irgendwann flach liegt lahm
liegt in den nächsten
wochen oder tagen das heißt das müsste
jetzt in deinem sinne eigentlich sein
quarantäne regeln verkürzen richtig
jetzt total aber ich bin ja auch ein
wenig begeistert von karl lauterbach das
hätte ich niemals in meinem ganzen leben
geglaubt ist aber so weil er jetzt auch
sagt ja wir werden uns die quarantäne
regelung anschauen also karl lauterbach
man merkt ja gerade die tat wenn er so
ein bisschen kaum ist er in
regierungsverantwortung wird er doch
etwas pragmatischer das gefällt mir gut
wie gefällt der neue karl lauterbach
ausgesprochen gut und ich hoffe dass
jetzt beim gipfel dann auch entschieden
wird dass wir meines erachtens nach
sollten wir dem beispiel in frankreich
folge leisten danach sind wir so ein
bisschen hin gerade im blindflug also
jeden tag zeit das rkw zahlen mit mit
dem hinweis dass hier kein vollständiges
bild geben aufgrund dieser zahlen werden
aber am freitag maßnahmen beschlossen
was für maßnahmen gewinnen da erwarten
kann man darauf laut entscheidungen
basieren der patrizia ich bin ja völlig
entgeistert was das rk ii gerade macht
also über die weihnachtstage war es so
gesehen im ferien modus viele
gesundheitsämter und eigentlich kann man
gerade gar nicht wissen wie das
infektionsgeschehen in deutschland ist
man hat ja ganz lange gesagt wir sollten
jetzt auch eher auf die hospitalisierung
raten schauen dann gibt's die inzidenz
sein ich habe ja auch bwl kurse
absolviert in meiner universität und
damals habe ich immer gelernt ein guter
manager macht erst selbst seine
hausaufgaben und dann verlangte er was
von anderen gesehen finde ich etwas
schwierig wie die regierung handelt die
zahlen selbst nicht im griff haben die
hausaufgaben nicht erledigt haben
blindflug für deutschland die zahlen wir
wissen nicht ob sie stimmen aber jetzt
wieder über maßnahmen für die bürger
reden ein guter manager würde anders
handeln er sollte die politik sich
endlich mal ein beispiel ein
wirtschaftsunternehmen handy
funktionieren da dürfte der gipfel aber
die stattfinden oder was ist deine
empfehlung eigentlich müsste man jetzt
hat sie ja so lange warten bis zahlen da
so ein kleines problem an dieser
argumentation es dauert sehr sehr lange
bezahlen die jemals irgendwann fragt
sich also ich muss auch ehrlich sagen
ich bin etwas verwundert warum man nicht
erst seine hausaufgaben seine zahlen im
griff hat und dann sich zusammensetzt da
ich aber ja dafür bin dass die krone
regeln gelockert werde die quarantäne
regeln gelockert werden sehe ich diesen
kronen gipfel mit gemischten gefühlen
entgegen ich habe mich aber was
mitgebracht wir hatten ja heute auf
seite 4 im bild ganz groß auch der
korona blindflug und zum beispiel der
haben kollegen aus dem politik ressort
haben in den einzelnen gesundheitsämtern
angerufen wie denn so die zahlen lage
ist ein gesundheitsamt hat gelacht dass
andere gesundheitsamt hat auf die frage
trauen sie den zahlen und zwar das
landratsamt im südlichen hessen hat
gesagt das ist so eine frage die kann
ich nicht beantworten da muss ich
ehrlich sagen als bürgerin fühle ich
mich da verarscht und deswegen mit blick
auf den corona gipfel teil ich finde es
auch ehrlich gesagt sehr sehr schwierig
ist jetzt wieder maßnahmen beschlossen
werden sollen ohne die zahlen lage zu
kennen jetzt aber jetzt sprechen wir
noch nie da über dein privatleben
das sind drücken nämlich auch alle
menschen dafür ist aber natürlich ein
grund warum wir darüber sprechen du
warst über silvester in rom jahr als du
dich besonders gewundert masken und du
das ist auch eine spezielle beziehung
war weder aber da hatte so ein erlebnis
das hatte ich ein bisschen ratlos
zurückgelassen ja also es ist ja erst
mal ganz bombastisch meine entscheidung
gewesen ich meine ich die nichts mehr
hasse als die maske zu tragen fliegt
über silvester in einem der strengsten
masse norden europas das muss man auch
erst mal gelingen bei der buchung es war
massen pflicht auf der straße ein
feuerwerk gab es auch nicht also
dementsprechende reise etwas
danebengegangen aber was mich dann
wirklich schockiert hat ich liebe das
ballett und ich war im nussknacker also
ich habe mich hingesetzt diese ft2 maske
aufgesetzt ich muss zugeben ich habe die
zwei stunden nicht ausgehalten im
ballett aber 20 minuten habe ich
geschafft immerhin und dann wegen
ballett oder wegen wegen der maske ich
konnte selbst nicht tragen dann hab ich
ist ballett dann auch noch zwei fast
aber auch warum ich es auch verlassen
hat war für mich halt kunst nichts mit
kronehat zu tun wenn ich schaue also
meinen geliebten nussknacker und was ist
die schauspieler tragen also die tänzer
tragen eine maske das muss man sich
wirklich überlegen maske im ballett bei
den schauspielern auf der bühne ich
finde es reicht also ich hab wirklich
ich saß dort völlig entgeistert und habe
mir gedacht die welt ist jetzt völlig
verrückt geworden maske
hochleistungssport ballett tanz ist
hochleistungssport und die stehen da mit
der maske tanzen mit der maske aber die
wichtigsten charaktere mussten keine
maske auf der bühne tragen also dass
auch das war dann noch via und da hatte
der nussknacker für mich an wert
verloren ich habe das ballett verlassen
und habe mich ins restaurant gegenüber
gesetzt wie sollten dann überhaupt wie
soll das in europa auf den bühnen
geregelt werden die theater die haben so
lange auch gelitten in der pandemie ganz
oft fiel der satz alle dürfen in den
vollen flugzeugen sitzen aber das
theaterhaus das muss dicht machen jetzt
berichtet von dieser erfahrung in rom
was glaubst du was soll sich die kunst
ein ständen die sollen die bühnen das in
europa denn lösen worüber man sicher
debattieren kann es auch mit blick auf
die hohen zahlen gerade aktuellen rom
ich mein ich hatte jetzt ein problem mit
der ft2 maske die zwei stunden zu tragen
aber darüber kann man debattieren ob die
zuschauer sie nicht tragen sollen ich
bin dagegen andere sind dafür aber was
ich wirklich nicht also überhaupt nicht
was mir gleich den kopf geht es wirklich
warum tänzer die ihren job aus ihm mit
maske hochleistungssport machen das
sollte nicht so sein ich finde da sind
wir deutschen machen ganz gutes beispiel
man geht ja mit maske rein ins kino
setzt sich hin oder ins theater und die
schauspieler auf der bühne tragen keine
maske ich finde da kann deutschland mal
sagen zum glück sind wir was die kunst
betrifft nicht die korona maßnahmen
weltmeister und das sollte auch so
bleiben als es hat mich sehr verstört in
rom und mein neuer als es ja kann nur
besser werden als meine rom aufenthalt
war